hat ein ästhetisch stadt sodom zerstört
ein forschungsteam hat nördlich des
toten meeres ein gebiet ausgemacht in
dem wahrscheinlich vor rund 3700 jahren
ein asteroid explodiert ist und dieses
ereignis hat das bis in die bibel
geschafft klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal aktiviert die glocke
denn nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
da macht dann plötzlich auch die
geschichte von sodom und gomorrha einen
sinnlos darf als einziger nach
vorwarnung durch zwänge die stadt mit
seiner familie verlassen doch seine frau
blickt trotz warnung zurück und er starb
zu einer salzsäure wenn man jetzt die
ergebnisse des forschungsteams
interpretiert sind die parallelen dieser
geschichte mit der realität frappierend
der archäologe dr philippe silvia von
der trinity south west university in
albuquerque arbeitet seit über 13 jahren
mit einem forschungsteam
sie haben den fundort thalhammer
ausgegraben auf dem jährlichen treffen
der american school of oriental research
haben sie ihre forschung präsentiert
demnach ist wahrscheinlich vor 3700
jahren ein asteroid in dieser region
noch in der luft explodiert und hat wie
in der bibel beschrieben schwefel und
feuer über das gebiet mittelbar gebracht
dort liegt die antike stadtteil hamm an
die von den vorstellen als sodom
angesehen wird die artikelbezeichnung
des toten meeres lautet nämlich mehr von
sodom oder im arabischen meer das lot
und auch die erzählung von lots frau und
ihrem erstarren zu einer salzsäure macht
sinn das forschungsteam geht nämlich
davon aus dass mit schwefel und feuer
die schockwelle das us-team gemeint war
und dass diese schockwelle dann noch
einen zweiten effekt hatte sie hat
nämlich einen teil des wasser des
salzhaltigen toten meeres verdampfen
lassen und dabei ist das salz des sees
als lauge über rund 500 quadratkilometer
land nieder gegangen und hat die region
für rund 600 jahre vergiftet an
landwirtschaft war dort nicht mehr zu
denken proben der ausgrabungen zeigen
dass ein extrem heißes und exklusives
ereignis die ganze fläche damals
verwüstet hat die forscherinnen vermuten
nämlich dass die intensiven stoßwellen
der explosion
auch mit einer überhitzten salzlösung
aus anhydrit salzen des toten meeres das
gebiet bedeckt haben könnten dass alles
passt in das bild der biblischen
erzählung erst 600 jahre später also
etwa 1000 100 vor christus konnte das
gebiet dann wieder besiedelt werden ein
noch größeres rätsel ist allerdings
dieses ungelöste rätsel um eine antike
maschine
das ist eine absolut irre geschichte mit
harald lesch anklicken also hier
anschauen und terrex natur und
geschichte abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran